Thank you for your balance on holistic medicine.
Um, example, Dr. Artis, it's a good reminder for all of us when we are ill, it's easy to be so
gullible. And it's not, I don't mean to be little anybody that's listening to these things and
like, oh my gosh, this could be the cure for everything. I'm just trying to remind you of, you know,
I see these all the time when it's like, it just, it, it infuriates me because they speak with
like such authority. Um, like they have all this data and, um, that, that they're going off of that
with, with the, with these great success on something and they don't, they're not even practicing
84. It's just like some books that are written about cancer that that aren't written by a person
that treats cancer. Where you coming up with the septal theoretical to sell a book. Uh, that just
bothers me. It's just like, where are the ethics and the morals of people? Maybe you don't have a
responsibility to your patient base because you don't have a patient base. But what about the
responsibility to humanity? When you're making claims that nobody can, nobody can justify those
claims that you're making. It's just theoretical. Um, you know, there's, I read a book on
Methyline Blue. A few years ago when Betheline Blue was this big thing and, and what's his name?
Mercola was big and they're Betheline Blue. And it was taking Betheline Blue. Of course he,
that was one of his biggest sellers. He was selling Betheline Blue at the time. And it's like,
so I read a book on it and I read some, looked up some data. The person that read a book,
all he does is write books on different natural things. He doesn't even do any of these things. He's
not a practitioner. You know, it's like, there's no, there's no, um, those people are immune to any,
any, um, you know, um, backlash because, you know, they're just writing, they're just writing to
write a book and it's, there's freedom of speech. So we just have to be careful in looking at
the information that is out there is have a balance to view of it. As all I'm saying, let's just
look at it with a critic. I think we should look at everything with a critical eye. I mean,
that's what I did when I got into all of this, you know, when I was first, you know, I got into
the right machine when I was in school, but the Lord didn't give me permission to buy my first
right. When I was in school, that was in the early 1980s. So the Lord didn't give me permission to buy my
first right until 1998. It was a long time. Okay. So I had studied the right and I picked out the
right machine that I wanted and then that changed over time. But I was looking at different machines.
Of course, they so much approved since 1998 when I bought my first right finally decided this was
going to be the right machine that I was going to buy when I was ready to buy it. And I thought it was
the best machine on the market at the time. And I think it was. I think I was right. And when that
first patient came in in 1990 and finally, I felt like the Holy Spirit gave me permission to buy a
rife. It took that long for that door to be opened. And then walk through that door and the rest
is history. But again, I've been willing to make changes based upon what I think is the best in my
knowledge and gaining knowledge over time, what I think is the best. And being very careful, you know,
I take, you know, when I'm trying to figure out what's the best thing for you and people that God has
given me to watch over, I take that responsibility as a very grave responsibility. So I'm not going to
lead you down the road just because we can sell a product or something. Or because there's a lot of
hype behind it. So I want to be that that factor that that that maybe puts the brakes on sometimes.
And this says, let's think about this. Let's pray about this. Let's be wise about this. Let's ask for
a wisdom about this. And let's use discernment in our judgment before we jump on a pen and bandwagon
that will, you know, could possibly make us look like a fool afterwards. So, or could hurt us.
So, let's just be careful with all of that.